fanboy or fangirl is a word to describe
not just a mere fan but a die-hard with
loyalty of steel and the obsessive
capability to write 20 things you didn't
know about Princess Leia times and
Imperial senator fanboys are fanatics
they coalesce into fandoms around nearly
anything even Microsoft you know what
than ideas don't you Bubba don't you but
mostly fanboys focus on sci-fi and
fantasy related movies comics books TV
series games and anything with a Marvel
logo on it to them these works are
precious and each year the leaders of
these followers descend onto san diego
california for the comic-con conference
afford a plastic saber-rattling nerd
fest now in its 44th year the event
brings together fan boys and girls of
different faiths comic lovers role
players tabletop gamers and others who
wish they lived in middle-earth Comic
Con includes over 50 sessions on
Dungeons and Dragons over 30 on magic
cards over 10 on Pokemon and many other
things you haven't heard mentioned since
1995 this year there is also a My Little
Pony card game tournament just let that
sink in
what else do fanboys do when they're not
geeking out over who's a better
superhero batman or superman oh the
fanboy rabbit hole is deep first there's
fan fiction where fans write sequels
prequels and alternate versions of their
favorite franchises like making Frodo
and Sam finally hook up at the end of
Return of the King then there's fan art
that hangs on the walls of tumblr
galleries and there's cosplay or costume
play where fan boys dress up as
characters from their beloved sagas I
take back everything I said about Civil
War reenactments so if you find yourself
overthinking the Hulk's backstory or if
you've ever signed an email with live
long and prosper you two might just be a
fanboy
worst word of the week ever